-Our next guest, a very talented
actress and comedian
you know from shows like "It's
Always Sunny in Philadelphia
and "24."
Her stand-up special,
"Mary Lynn Rajskub:
Live From the Pandemic,"
is available to rent or ow
on Vimeo.
Let's take a look.
-My divorce started
when my husband left me.
He is so quiet.
I did not hear him leave.
I just kept
walking past the bathroom.
I was like,
"Something is different.
Something is different."
And then I realized
that one of the electric
toothbrushes was missing.
Like, "Oh! That guy
that I'm married to."
-[ Laughs ]
Please welcome back to the sho
our friend Mary Lynn Rajskub
How are you?
-Hi. Just in love
with watching myself.
Oh, look at this!
-Oh, wow!
See, that's so nice,
because we're losing --
A whole generation of guests
aren't getting the freebie mug
because they're not here
in person.
Oh, look at the tote!
-Ah?
I mean, we're saving a fortune
not having to give that stuf
away anymore.
-For a price,
I would be willing to give thi
to a very special guest
or back to you.
I would sell it back to you,
if you'd like.
-It doesn't have too much
sentimental value for you?
-Uh, well, I have used it
as my pillow for a long time
And I -- I don't like to hoard
-Sure.
-So it does have
my energy on it.
-Oh, so it should sell
for a premium then.
-Yes.
I mean,
I don't want to get too funky,
but I have put it
out in the moonlight,
and, like a crystal,
it soaked up the energy
of my desires and dreams.
Um...
I'm that glad that,
when you showed my clip,
it didn't show the end
of the joke, which is --
It says, "He's so quiet,
I didn't see him leave,
but then I'm so spacey,
I forgot that I told him
to get the F out."
[ Laughter ]
I'm glad you didn't show
that part, 'cause that's mean.
And I also want
to state for the record
I had a very easy, nice divorce,
and I'm very thankful for that
-I think that's very good
to lay it out for the record
This was -- Hopefully, peopl
could tell from the clip,
one, it was in your garage
two, there was no audience
Obviously,
this is incredibly unique.
How was that experience of
filming a special like that?
-Well, listen, I was
about to record a comedy album
in front of an audience,
and then the pandem, you know?
And then I was coming up
with all kinds of new material
'cause I had a lot of time
and I was up in my head.
And I got together the tea
and said,
"Let's do it in the garage."
And, yes, there was a little bit
of audience there.
They didn't give me
any clap back.
It was just the refrigerator
the Amazon truck
behind the garage,
and my dog licking
from the toilet bowl.
That was the only heckle
that I got.
And I could totally handle it,
you know?
I don't need an audience.
I totally relate
to what you were just saying
Like, good, you know?
I'm good with just me.
I mean, it's probably --
I should probably
not be left alone to my ow
devices much longer, you know?
-Right.
-I don't know how healthy it i
to just do a show for yourself
-Well, it's -- it's not --
Still doing it for people.
-Yes.
-I just feel as though at leas
for this brief period of time,
removing the middle man
isn't the worst thing
in the world.
-I know. It's not, is it?
Could I be on your show
every day?
-We would love to have you
Now, one of the things --
you were ready a little bi
for no audience,
because you did --
Much like many stand-ups,
you found ways to do
Zoom stand-up comedy shows
These are not easy.
I've done a few little things.
The weird thing is,
do you prefer
to have all your Zoom audience
muted or unmuted?
What do you like?
-You have to have unmuted.
I mean, the times
where it's been muted,
you really are in a vortex
'Cause you know what's worse
than doing a show --
Which is not worse.
It was pretty magical, the sho
that I did in my garage.
It was fantastic.
It's a lot of fun.
But when you are on a Zoom
with no voices
and you're not sure
how many people are there,
and you see your own face in
front of you is the weirdest -
It's like you just
beamed into another --
You beamed yourself
out of your planet.
And who are you talking to
I mean, we're talking right now,
but I'm not with you, you know
holding your hand like
I normally would when we talk.
-No, I think
that's what people remembe
about when you've been here,
is you're the only guest
where we hold hands
the whole time.
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
-You -- People -- A lot of
people know you from "24,"
and this led to people
coming to see you
because I think a lot of peopl
who knew you first from "24" -
I wasn't one of those people -
were surprised to find out
that you're an accomplishe
stand-up,
and then those people
would come out to see you.
Were "24" fans
good stand-up fans?
-The first time I went on th
road proper, "24" was just -
It was still on the air,
and I got to the club --
my first time doing
a road gig for the weekend
"You sold out all shows!"
I was like,
"I sold out all shows!"
Well, Chloe O'Brian
sold the shows.
And the people
that want to see Chloe O'Brian
do not want to see comedy,
it turns out.
I could have just
not done the stand-up
and just taken a photo
with everybody
and let them go back home
to their TVs
to watch more episodes of "24.
They weren't ready for my take
on a modern woman, motherhood,
and what it's really like to b
an international superstar
Oh, we'll get into it.
They were like
deer in the headlights.
Like, I really took them t
places they weren't expecting.
-You do talk about your family
a fair amount.
You talk about being a mother.
Does your son
think you're funny?
-We do not share
the same sense of humor,
although, you know --
I'll be disciplining him,
and he's like,
"I pooped in my pants!"
And I'm like -- I'm saying
can you take a screen break?
And he's like,
"I pooped my pants, Mom!
It's funny! You don't get it
You're a comedian."
And I'm like, "No, man.
It's not bussin'. Okay? No cap."
And so he doesn't laugh at me,
and I don't laugh at him.
It's just a missed --
It's a missed --
I don't get his TikToks.
He doesn't get my TikToks.
-How old is he?
-He's 12.
-He's 12, yeah.
Well, he shouldn't be
pooping his pants.
-He may as well be 17.
-Yeah.
-Like, I don't know how
he could get to be
more of a teenager right now
-Congratulations on pulling of
what very few have managed to do
during this pandemic,
which is a new stand-up special,
which so many people
are thirsty for.
Thanks for being here.
It's always great to see you
Hopefully next time in person.
-Thanks for having me.
-"Mary Lynn Rajskub:
Live From the Pandemic"
is available on Vimeo.